So you have a good understanding
of focus styles and
leveraging Aria in your CSS.
We've also talked about the double
when you get from using fluid and
responsive styles in your app, to both
improve the multi device experience and
accessibility.
The last series I want to touch
on are the roles that color and
contrast should play
in your application.
If you have good vision, it's really
easy to fall into the trap of thinking
that everyone perceives colors or
text legibility the same way that you
do, but evidence proves otherwise.
So let's wrap things up by looking at
how we can effectively use color and
contrast to create pleasant designs
that are accessible to everyone.